وعشرون يوما مرت على معركه الذبح في بخموت
بحسب وصف واشنطن حتى سيطرت روسيا على
المدينه قوه باجنر بقياده بريكوشن بدات
تسليم المدينه للدفاع الروسيه لكن ماذا
بعد
الواقعه شرق اوكرانيا تقع على بعد نحو 65
كيلو مترا شمال مدينه دانياس وعلى بعد 15
كيلومترا عن حدود بالسيطره عليها يمكن ان
تكون خطوه روسيا التاليه التقدم غربا
والسيطره على السبيانس وكرامه وهو ما يعني
ان الجيش الروسي سيكون امامه طريق مفتوح
للسيطره على باقي دومباس القتال الذي
خاضته روسيا في بخموت حتى سيطرت عليها تم
تقسيمه لمحورين بعد فشل القوات في تطبيق
القوات الاوكرانيه داخل المدينه كلفت قوات
باجنار باقتحام المدينه من الشرق وصولا
للغرب عبر القتال في الشوارع
امر جعل تكلفه الانتصار عاليه جدا فيما
تكفل الجيش الروسي بحمايه المدينه شمالا
وجنوبا حيث كانت الاشتباكات في الحقول
والقرى هذه الاستراتيجيه جعلت روسيا تسيطر
كليا على ما يفيدها في منع الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد
نحن ندرك انه بعد بخمت بامكانهم الذهاب
ابعد من ذلك الى كراماتورسك وسلوفيانسك
سيكون الطريق مفتوحا امام الروس الى مدن
اخرى في اوكرانيا باتجاه ديونيتسك
بالمنطق العسكري وبحسب عدد من المحللين
العسكريين لا يحتاج الجيش الروسي الان الى
فيغنر وخصوصا بعد السيطره على بخموت
مقاتلوها مرهقون معنوياتهم منخفضه وهنا
يحاول بريغوجن تقويه المجموعه واخيرا ظهرت
تقارير تتحدث عن انضمام الجنرال روما نائب
القائد السابق للحرس الوطني الروسي
والجنرال ميخائيل ميزانسيب نائب وزير
الدفاع السابق الى باقنر بعد اقالتهما من
الخدمه المدنيه لكن قد يكون هذا الامر
مقدمه او بدايه استيلاء على باجنر من قبل
الكريملين وذلك بحسب بلاد الميكانينكو
الخبير في الشؤون الروسيه فكره اخرى
تقلقوش وانتقد الكرملين علنا بسببها الشهر
الماضي انشاء شركات عسكريه خاصه جديده
بدلا من دعم داكنر
موجودين
ليكون السؤال الان ماذا لو استمر قائد
فاجنر في انتقاداته للكرملين وفي سعيه
للاشتباك مع المسؤولين العسكريين
السيناريوهات عديده احداها تخلص
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات